the book cover and summary for escape
from the Isle of the Lost is finally
here dissidents fans have been eagerly
awaiting the release of the newest novel
in the series and while they will have
to wait a few more months for the actual
release of the book we've got some
wicked clues and theories about our
favorite villain kids watch until the
end for the most a mind-blowing clue
that a fan found in The Descendants
short story under the scene okay first
let's talk about the cover of the book
the title is scrolled over what looks
like a blue flaming jewel it's similar
to the glowing blue orb we saw in the
teaser for descendants three you know
the one that was whispering mouths name
before she called it dad fans are pretty
sure that blue flame represents Hades
from Hercules for the following reasons
Cheyenne Jackson has been cast for The
Descendants 3 film to play the role of
Hades name is Hades Lord of the Dead
hater
therefore Hades must have a significant
part to play in the story Hades has blue
flaming hair in the Disney movie
Hercules that blue orb in the forest and
on the cover of the escape from the Isle
of the Lost
there's a striking resemblance to the
flaming blue hair on Hades head it makes
sense that Maleficent would hook up with
the god of the underworld upon further
inspection of the blue flaming jewel on
the cover of the new book it appears to
have a face with a sneer out of
curiosity we did a side-by-side
comparison of the face in the blue flame
next to the picture of Cheyenne Jackson
you can kind of see the resemblance
check out that sneer but what does that
blue flame when the book cover have to
do with now well if you look at the
background behind the flame you'll see
that it's purple which is now signature
color it also kind of looks like dragon
scales so it's safe to say that in the
book now in Hades are connected in some
way now that we've explored the cover of
the new novel let's discuss the summary
of the book it states that while the
villain kids may have once been the
baddest of the bad and their wicked ways
are mostly behind them it seems they are
preparing to graduate from auradon prep
and you know that their caps and gowns
will be
custom-designed and specially made by
Eevee but before they can put on their
fabulous grad outfits they've got an
epic plan to put into action they want
to help other villain kids who are stuck
on the Isle of the loss to have a chance
to come to our don prep the synopsis
mentions Cecelia dr. facile ears
daughter referring to her as a trickster
wanting to be in on that deal to leave
the Isle for a better life
so mal Evie Carlos and jaye plan a visit
to the aisle to make this happen
of course uma who is trapped on the
other side of the barrier is still
fuming from the last time now defeated
her she's looking for revenge against
mal and will stop at nothing to get it
so according to the book summary uma
discovers an underground lair belonging
to Hades and realizes she has found the
perfect partner in crime they team up
with the goal to defeat mal bring down
the barrier and escape the Isle for good
the book promises an explosive
underwater battle between mal and uma
which could determine the destiny of
auradon and the Isle of the Lost
once and for all after reading this
teaser we have so many burning questions
like his Hades mouthed father and if he
is why would he team up with her nemesis
to defeat her what bro will celia and
dr. fossil ear play in the story and
what's going on with audrey from the
pictures of her and her new outfit it
looks like she has turned evil will she
have a part to play in scheming for
Emma's revenge against mal
thank goodness for a fandom they've got
some solid theories on what may be in
store in the new book and a subsequent
film and we've got a huge theory we
haven't seen anywhere else here's a hint
it's got everything to do with that
necklace dizzy was wearing and under the
sea a descendent short story but before
we get into that let's highlight a few
fan theories that are floating around
out there the first interesting theory
we found has to do with Audrey she's got
a wicked new look for the new film so
fans are speculating that she has turned
evil but none of them are completely
sure why it could be that she is
possessed by someone one fan thinks she
drank poison created by Hades in order
to turn her into a villain that
and points to the serum that Hades
created in the Disney film Hercules you
know the one that gets pain and panic to
feed to baby Herc to make him immortal
so it was Audrey drinking a sinister
cocktail crafted by Hades or is it just
a green juice because cackling made her
thirsty
who knows but one thing is for sure
Audrey has completely transformed since
she was introduced as the sweet demure
princess from the first dissonance film
I totally do not blame you for your
mother trying to kill my parents and
stuff another fan thinks that Audrey may
have made a deal with dr. facile ear or
maybe his daughter Celia which caused
this wicked transformation this fan
believes that mouth' dad is trying to
warn her in the enchanted forest
they point to a scene from The Princess
and the Frog it's the scene where dr.
facile ear makes a deal with the princes
sidekick
Laurence dr. facile ears tarot cards
have the magical power of being able to
show someone the person that they want
to be for Laurence it was royalty
so dr. facile ears stole a bit of the
Prince navin's blood stuck in an Italian
and put the talisman around at
Lawrence's neck this made Laurence
appear to be prince naveen while the
real prince was hopping around covered
in frog slime the book synopsis mentions
dr. facile ears daughter Celia and calls
her a trickster so maybe she picked up
some of her father's tarot card trickery
it's possible that audrey was so jealous
of now for being in line to become
princess of auradon that she actually
wants to be mal and she might still be
bent out of shape for the whole thing
where maleficent cast a wicked spell on
her mom causing her to go into the
longest period of beauty sleep ever
not to mention mao stole Audrey's
boyfriend then yeah there's a lot going
on there
one fan noticed a major clue in the end
credits of the under-the-sea short when
the descendants three title comes up on
screen a tarot card flies out if you
slowed down the frames the way this
clever fan did you'll see that the card
shows a picture of mal on it
so did Celia or her father show this
card revealing the truth of who Audrey
wants to be does Audrey wish she was mal
if so it would make sense that she would
make a deal
can take what she believes is rightfully
hers here's another major discovery
about Audrey if you look at the set pics
of her in her new evil costume you'll
see something familiar she is holding
Maleficent scepter where did she get
that one van was quick to point out that
of a human who is not related to
Maleficent touches her scepter a spell
will be cast that causes them to sleep
for 1,000 years
Audrey seems pretty awake in the
pictures that's pretty suspicious don't
you think but if the story surrounds
Audrey and mal where I do uma and Hades
come into the equation another possible
theory is that mal and uma have a hidden
history that goes away back we all know
who Emma's mother is Ursula the sea
witch has never been the shy type but
who is Emma's father the same could be
said about mal she is clearly
Maleficent's daughter that's obvious
from the green eyes and the dragon
morphing ability as they both have but
there has been so much mystery as to who
mal sad is it's highly likely that Hades
is her father but who is to say that
Hades didn't have other romantic
interests as well namely a certain white
haired octopus with a very bad agenda he
is quite a catch isn't he so what if
Ursula and Hades were a thing before or
after Maleficent and Hades hooked up to
create mal that would mean that luma and
now our half sisters yikes
that's gonna make for some awkward
family get-togethers if that's true it's
possible that Hades has a favorite
daughter maybe the fact that mal went to
auradon and became good is a huge
problem for the god of the underworld
and mounded kind of contribute to
turning Hades X Maleficent into a lizard
so maybe he's peeved at now for denying
her evil roots uma however seems to be
all-in when it comes to villainy and bad
deeds
so did Hades an uma team-up to teach mal
a lesson she won't forget or is he
actually trying to warn her that
something bad is about to happen these
are all pretty incredible theories but
we think we've got them beat check this
out
you remember The Descendants short under
the sea well in this short story a
necklace
Dizzy's chest starts glowing then all of
the sudden dizzy is speaking with ullas
voice and has all her mannerisms
this is when Mao points out that dizzy
is wearing umas necklace uma speaks
through dizzy she says that her necklace
is actually wearing dizzy then she pulls
Dizzy's glasses off of her face drops
them and stomps on them not cool uma
anyway mal runs away and jumps into the
water she faces off with uma in a super
cool dance fight water ballet sequence
while singing stronger by Kelly Clarkson
suddenly mal wakes up from the trance
and sees normal dizzy standing in front
of her they take off through the woods
because Malkin since that era darn is in
danger after Mao's foot we see uma a
shell necklace glowing and we hear
Emma's voice saying that mal is in
danger and that she won't see it coming
that's a pretty dark and foreboding
statement from uma looking at Emma's
magic necklace we couldn't help but feel
that we had seen something like that
before dr. Vasily are used a talisman to
transform Laurence into the prince
Ursula used that shell necklace to steal
Ariel's voice in the Little Mermaid it
seems possible that uma could have
borrowed her mother's necklace for some
evil plot involving her vengeance
against mal it's clear that umas
necklace has the power to possess people
and make even good kids do very bad
things when we saw this picture of
Audrey drinking her juice we noticed
something interesting if you look
closely you'll see a substantial
necklace hanging around her neck if you
zoom in you'll see that it kind of looks
like a dragon so it's not in the shape
of a shell like the one around Izzy's
neck when she's possessed by uma it kind
of makes sense if Audrey wants to be mal
a dragon necklace might be appropriate
but did Audrey make a deal with dr.
facile ear or Celia to become queen bee
of the aisle if so maybe her talisman is
this dragon charm or did you may use a
necklace to possess Audrey to make her
turn evil maybe Audrey has no idea what
she is doing at all and uma is calling
all of the shots but then why is Audrey
holding Maleficent sceptre seer
what is she doing with that scepter fans
are hoping all will be revealed when the
book comes out but will the book hit the
shelves before the movie comes out it's
possible that the movie will deviates
from the book this will definitely keep
fans guessing everyone is wondering what
uma Hades dr. facile ear and Celia all
have in common maybe their only common
thread is that they are all stuck on the
Isle of the Lost and they want to be
free but will Hades be on uma sides or
is he trying to warn mal about danger on
the horizon also where are Evy Carlos
and J we haven't seen him in the teaser
or the short story if fans want to know
what's in the book they're going to have
to wait until it's official release in
June of this year so what do you think
is there a necklace possessing people to
turn evil is Hades on uma side or mouths
and where's the rest of mouths crew and
what's up with Audrey tell us what your
theories are in the comments and those
are the descendants three clues we found
from the newest book escape from the
Isle of the Lost
what theory did you like the best tell
us in the comments and don't forget to
subscribe to the things thanks for
watching and see you soon
[Music]